Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit, dem neuen Podcast-Projekt des DLR und der ESA. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle sehr herzlich, die sich hier entschlossen haben, gleich in die erste Folge dieser Reihe einzuschalten. Raumzeit, das ist eine Serie von Gesprächen mit Experten aus allen Bereichen der Raumfahrt, aus Forschung, aber auch Betrieb, Wissenschaftler und Leute aus der Organisation, zahlreicher Unternehmungen und Projekte. Wir wollen hier einen Blick wagen auf die Dimension der Raumfahrt im europäischen und auch im deutschen Kontext. Technologien hinterfragen und die Aufgaben der Raumfahrt auch hier diskutieren. Grundsätzlich soll es also Einblicke geben in allerlei wissenschaftliche, technische und Projektdetails und Hintergründe, die hier interessant sind. Und das ist natürlich ein weites Feld. Und als Einstieg in diese Serie möchte ich einen Überblick liefern über die Dimensionen, die die Raumfahrt hat in Europa und in Deutschland. Und dafür begrüße ich Jan Wörner. Schönen guten Tag. Sie sind der Vorstandsvorsitzende des Deutschen Zentrums für Luft- und Raumfahrt, DLR, sozusagen der oberste deutsche Raumfahrer. Kann man das so sagen?
Das kann man so sagen.
Seit wann begleiten Sie dieses Amt?
Ja, ich habe hier angefangen am 1. März 2007. Das heißt, ich mache das jetzt etwas mehr als drei Jahre und bin ja jemand, der ganz aus einem anderen Bereich kommt. Ich bin eigentlich Bauingenieur. Das war schon für mich ein sehr heftiger Berufswechsel von Universitätspräsidentin zum Deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt. Ich kann nur sagen, es ist eine faszinierende Welt, die sich hier aufgetan hat, auch für mich beruflich. Deshalb bin ich mit voller Begeisterung dabei.
Gibt es denn da eine Verbindung?
Es gibt viele Verbindungen. Ich hatte natürlich damals, als ich mich um dieses Amt beworben habe, auch selber mir die Frage gestellt, ist das überhaupt sinnvoll? Kann ein Bauingenieur eine solche Position begleiten? Ich war vorher Unipräsident. Da ist das klar. Man hat in dem Fall 13 Fachbereiche. Man kann gar nicht der Experte von 13 Fachbereichen sein. Insofern ist das eigentlich ganz egal, bei einer Hochschule, aus welchem Fach man kommt. Und eine ähnliche Argumentation habe ich dann auch hier vorgetragen. Das DLR steht ja nicht nur für Raumfahrt, es steht für Luftfahrt, es steht für Energie, für Verkehr und Sicherheitsforschung. Und es ist natürlich sehr schwer, einen Experten für alle Bereiche zu finden. Das wäre aber nicht genügend. Dann könnte man ja jeden Beliebigen nehmen oder jede Beliebige. Ich habe dann versucht, auch mir selber klarzumachen, was in meiner Entwicklung an Themen mit dem DLR im Zusammenhang schon gelaufen ist. Und tatsächlich habe ich sehr viel gefunden. Ich habe für Flugzeugtriebwerke Teststände gebaut als Bauingenieur. Da musste ich mich auch mit den Triebwerken auseinandersetzen. Ich habe Flugzeugabsturzberechnungen durchgeführt, um die Gebäude sicher zu machen. Das ist natürlich nicht das, was die Luftfahrer gern hören. Aber damit musste ich mich trotzdem auseinandersetzen. Mit den Flugzeugstrukturen, um zu wissen, welche Kräfte auf das Gebäude wirken. Ich habe im Bereich Energie zum Beispiel Solaranlagen als Bauingenieur konzipiert und auch Kraftwerke. Ich habe im Bereich Verkehr S-Bahnlinien trassiert. Das war überall leicht. Das Schwierigste war tatsächlich der Bereich Raumfahrt. Da auf meine Kindheit zu verweisen und die diversen Raketenprojekte, die ich da umgesetzt hätte, wäre nicht so richtig überzeugend gewesen. Ich habe damals einen Trick angewandt und habe versucht, nachzuweisen, dass ich etwas weiß, was sonst ganz wenige nur wissen. Und zwar ist es so gewesen bei den Amerikanern. Da gab es die Mercury-7-Gruppe. Mercury war die erste Kapsel. Und es gab diese 7 astronauten, die die ersten astronautenamerikaner waren, John Glenn und andere. Deshalb hießen auch diese ganzen Raumschiffe damals irgendwie immer Friendship 7 oder so. Und man stellt sich die Frage, warum 7? Und warum nur 7 Männer? Warum keine Frauen? Und es gab tatsächlich 13 Frauen in diesem ersten Astronautenkorps. Zusammen 20. Das macht sofort Logik, weil das eine Zahl ist, die wir glaube ich in unserem westlichen System als eine normale Zahl sehen. 10 oder 20 oder 15, aber nicht 7.
Obwohl die 7 hat ja auch durchaus so weiche 7. 7-Mahl-Hinstiefel.
Genau. Aber diese 13 Frauen sind von der NASA niemals zum Fliegen zugelassen worden. Weil man damals Angst hatte, wir reden jetzt über Ende der 50er Jahre des vorigen Jahrhunderts, dass das in dem Kongress sofort zu Widerstand führen würde, dass man Frauen in Raumkapseln setzt.
Also im amerikanischen Kongress.
Ja, im amerikanischen. Und deshalb sind diese 13 Frauen zwar ausgebildet worden, aber keine von denen ist jemals geflogen. Und diese Geschichte ist absolut unbekannt. Ich kannte sie durch Zufall durch eine Wissenschaftlerin, die das bei einem Vortrag erzählt hatte. Und das habe ich benutzt, um zu zeigen, also an der Stelle weiß ich ein kleines bisschen, was viele andere nicht wissen. Und habe letztlich dann überzeugen können.
So wird man ein Präsident sozusagen.
Ja, jeder muss seine Methode finden.
Aber was macht denn für Sie selbst jetzt die besondere Faszination der Raumfahrt aus?
Ja, also um das nochmal zu sagen, ich habe ja eben schon kurz auf meine Kind- und Jugendzeit zurückverwiesen. Ich habe tatsächlich alle Raumfahrt-Projekte immer verfolgt. Ich bin als Fünfjähriger von meinem Vater auf den Arm genommen worden und da hat gesagt, da oben fliegt der Sputnik. Ich habe nichts gesehen, aber ich habe ihm zugestimmt. Und seit der Zeit hat mich das Thema Raumfahrt immer begleitet. Ich habe alle Mondmissionen, sowohl der Russen als auch der Amerikaner, verfolgt. Nicht nur verfolgt, einfach davon gehört, sondern ich habe große Mondkarte in meinem Zimmer gehabt und habe alle aufgetragen, wo es wer, wann, wie gelandet. Ich habe auch die ganzen Nächte, die es damals gab, um die Mondmissionen live zu verfolgen, verfolgt. Auch dann, als das Interesse so langsam etwas abebte, Apollo 16, 17. Also ich war da immer begeistert. Und diese Begeisterung, ich glaube, das ist etwas, was wichtig ist für einen Beruf, wenn man begeistert hinter den Themen steht. Dasselbe könnte ich jetzt für die Luftfahrt erzählen und auch für die anderen Themen. Ich habe da überall so im privaten Bereich eine große Begeisterung gehabt. Und ich glaube, das ist eine wichtige Voraussetzung, dass man nicht den Beruf als Job nur sieht, bei dem man am Monatsende irgendeine Geldsumme überwiesen bekommt, sondern dass man sie als Berufung sieht. Und da hatte ich halt Glück.
Ja, das DLR ist ja eine sehr spezielle Organisation hier in Deutschland, der sie hier vorstehen. Wir haben es schon angesprochen, es gibt verschiedene Bereiche. Die Raumfahrt ist ein Teil davon, aber eben war Leib nicht die einzige. Schon im Titel hört man ja, Luftfahrt, Forschung spielt hier auch eine große Rolle. Wie wichtig sind denn die einzelnen Komponenten? Welche Rolle spielen diese einzelnen Gruppen?
Das DLR hat mit seiner Konstruktion tatsächlich eine Situation, die es weltweit zu einem ganz wichtigen Player macht. Wir sind Forschungszentrum. Dort machen wir Luftfahrt, Raumfahrt, Energieverkehr und Sicherheit. Und wir machen sie nicht getrennt voneinander, sondern wir verbinden die Themen. Also wenn wir zum Beispiel über einen Sateliten nachdenken und dessen Energieversorgung, dann können wir gleich wieder unsere Energiefachleute dazu nehmen. Oder wenn wir einen Zug entwickeln, einen Hochgeschwindigkeitszug, dann können wir für die Aerodynamik auf unsere Luftfahrt-Erfahrung zurückgreifen. Also das ist der Forschungsteil der DLR. Und dieser Forschungsteil lebt sehr stark von den internen Synergien. Wir sind aber mehr als das. Wir sind gleichzeitig auch die Raumfahrt-Agentur der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Wir haben durch ein Gesetz, das sogenannte komplizierter Name Raumfahrt-Aufgabenübertragungsgesetz, von dem Parlament, von dem Bundestag die Aufgabe übertragen bekommen, für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland Raumfahrt zu gestalten. Das heißt, wir machen mehr als nur unsere eigene Forschung. Wir machen gleichzeitig, sind wir eine Raumfahrt-Agentur. Da sind wir übrigens weisungsgebunden unmittelbar in dieser Tätigkeit. Wir nennen das intern das Raumfahrt-Management. Es ist ein eigener Bereich, der auch von dem anderen Bereich, von dem Forschungszentrumsbereich durchaus abgetrennt ist. Und diesem Raumfahrt-Management-Bereich organisieren wir jetzt nationale Projekte, nationale Raumfahrtmissionen, aber auch die europäischen Missionen, also der Europäischen Weltraum-Agentur ESA. Die werden nämlich auch vom DLR im Auftrag der Bundesrepublik Deutschland begleitet, betreut und auch mit Mitteln versehen.
Das ist ja sehr auffällig, wie man das eigentlich auch gewohnt ist in Europa. Das ist alles ein sehr auf den ersten Blick unüberschaubares Geflecht einzelner Institutionen und Länder-Zuteilungen. Ist denn jetzt die Rolle des DLR innerhalb von Deutschland jetzt eine einmalige Geschichte oder finden sich ähnliche Strukturen auch in anderen europäischen Ländern?
Also es gibt in vielen europäischen Ländern Raumfahrt-Agenturen. Unterschiedlich stark ausgeprägt, in Frankreich sehr stark, die CNES, in anderen Ländern etwas schwächer, Italien ist auch sehr stark mit der ASI. Es gibt Einrichtungen, die, wie das DLR, verschiedenen Themen zugeordnet sind. Aber das DLR mit dieser Konstruktion, Raumfahrt-Agentur einerseits und Forschungszentrum nicht nur auf die Raumfahrt begrenzt, sondern gleichzeitig auch Luftfahrt und so weiter, die anderen Themen, das ist schon eine Stärke, die uns von vielen abhebt. Allenfalls ähnlich noch die NASA. Die NASA, die amerikanische Raumfahrt-Agentur, die ist nämlich auch Raumfahrt-Agentur der Amerikaner. Und sie ist gleichzeitig ein Forschungszentrum. Sie bearbeitet insbesondere die Themen Luft- und Raumfahrt. Das weiß man auch nicht so stark in Deutschland. Aber NASA ist an der Stelle sehr vergleichbar. Also europäisch finden wir das weniger. Die NASA baut jetzt auch einen Bereich Energie auf. Also das sieht man, dass offensichtlich unser Modell auch dort wirkt. Und in Japan ist es die JAXA, die japanische Weltraum-Agentur, die ebenfalls eine ähnliche Struktur hat, die einen Agenturbereich hat und einen eigenen Forschungsbereich und auch etwas in der Raumfahrt und auch weniger in der Luftfahrt macht. Also wir sind dort schon besonders gut aufgestellt. Ich sage nicht nur besonders, sondern besonders gut aufgestellt, weil wir aus diesen verschiedenen Kompetenzen, die wir haben, immer wieder Vorteile ziehen und deshalb auch, wenn wir an der einen oder anderen Stelle weniger Geld haben, als unsere Wettbewerber, doch auf Augenhöhe miteinander arbeiten können. Die Franzosen geben deutlich mehr Geld aus für die Raumfahrt, aber wir brauchen uns nicht vor denen zu verstecken. Das DLR hat im Wesentlichen zunächst erst mal Mittel, die wir vom Bundestag zugewiesen bekommen. Wir sind Teil des Bundeshaushalts. Wir bekommen also dort Mittel für diese Raumfahrt-Agenturtätigkeit. Das ist noch mal unterteilt in den europäischen Abschnitt, etwa 600 Millionen, und einen nationalen Abschnitt, etwa 200 Millionen, also zusammen 800 Millionen. Ich mache es jetzt sehr rund. In Wirklichkeit sind die Differenzen zu den wirklichen Zahlen würden mir als privates Einkommen schon ausreichen. Und dann haben wir in diesem Forschungszentrumsbereich, dort bekommen wir von der Bundesregierung oder von dem Parlament noch mal etwa 300 Millionen. Und dann haben wir dadurch, dass wir aktiv sind im Trittmittelgeschäft, noch mal dieselbe Höhe von 300 Millionen aus anderen Quellen. Das können öffentliche Quellen sein, aber auch private Quellen. Wenn Sie das alles zusammennehmen, liegen wir so etwa bei 1,4, im Moment sogar ein bisschen drüber, Milliarden Euro, die wir als DLR insgesamt zur Verfügung haben. Das ist noch ein weiterer Punkt, aber der spielt jetzt hier nicht die große Rolle. Wir sind auch noch Projektträger für mehrere Ministerien. Wenn man das auch noch addieren würde, käme noch eine wesentlich größere Summe raus. Aber ich lasse es mal bei dem Forschungszentrum und dem sogenannten Raumfahrtmanagement.
Das DLR ist ja auf verschiedene Standorte verteilt hier in Deutschland. Wir sind jetzt hier gerade in Köln, dem vermutlich größten.
Ungefähr. Also wir haben mehrere große Standorte. Wir haben 13 Standorte in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Die reichen von Neustrelitz im Nordosten, das ist in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, bis Weilheim im Südwesten, das ist in Bayern. Wir haben Standorte wie Braunschweig, wie Stuttgart, wie Oberpfaffenhofen, Köln, Bremen, Hamburg. Also wir sind verteilt über die ganze Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Das ist etwas eine große Stärke. Man könnte zunächst mal glauben, dass das eine Schwierigkeit ist, wenn die Forscher jetzt plötzlich über hunderte von Kilometern zusammenarbeiten müssen. Aber wir haben festgestellt, dass die regionalen Verbünde dadurch gestärkt werden, also mit den jeweiligen Universitäten in der Umgebung. Und gleichzeitig haben wir im DLR eine perfekte Konstruktion, um über Standorte hinweg miteinander zusammenzuarbeiten. Wir sind aber auch in der Welt noch aktiv. Wir sind in Inuvik im Nordwesten Kanadas, nördlich des Polarkreises mit einer Antennenstation. Und wir sind ganz im Süden, O'Higgins, das ist eine Antarktis. Und wir sind in Mexiko präsent. Und wir sind in Paris, haben wir ein Büro, und in Brüssel. Also wir sind weltweit aktiv und das ist eine Stärke des DLR.
Ich fand es ganz interessant, dass, wenn man sich im Detail anschaut, dass DLR in seiner Struktur eher der NASA ähnelt. Man würde auf den ersten Blick vermuten, dass das ja das Äquivalent eigentlich die ESA sein müsste, die europäische Raumfahrtagentur. Dem scheint ja nicht so zu sein.
Ja, die ESA ist nun ganz dezidiert auf die Frage Raumfahrt ausgerichtet. Die ESA macht keine Luftfahrt oder irgendwelche anderen Themen. Und die ESA ist schon in dem Raumfahrtbereich auch ähnlich wie wir. Aber wie gesagt, diese anderen Themen, die wir noch aufgreifen, da ähneln wir doch eher der NASA oder der JAXA.
Ja, welche Rolle spielt jetzt die ESA in diesem Geflecht? Welches Verhältnis hat das DLR zu ESA? Welches Verhältnis hat die ESA zu den anderen Gruppierungen?
Ich sagte ja vorhin ganz kurz, dass auch die Mittel für die ESA über das DLR fließen, also von der Bundes-, vom Bundestag über das Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und Technologie zum DLR und vom DLR dann zur ESA, zur Europäischen Weltraumagentur. Und dafür bedarf es dann in der ESA natürlich auch einer entsprechenden Vertretung der deutschen Interessen. Und diese deutschen Interessen nimmt das DLR wahr. Das heißt, ich als Person, als Vorstandsvorsitzender des DLRs, bin Head of Delegation, also der Delegationsleiter der deutschen Delegation in der ESA. Und die ESA ist so konstruiert, dass die ESA hat eine eigene Exekutive, das sind Direktoren. Sie hat einen Generaldirektor, aber sie hat vor allen Dingen einen Council, einen ESA-Rat. Und dieser ESA-Rat, der entscheidet über die verschiedenen Dinge, die gemacht werden sollen und wie sie gemacht werden sollen. Und in diesem ESA-Rat sind alle 18 Mitgliedsstaaten mit einer Stimme vertreten. One country, one vote. Unabhängig davon, wie viel Geld sie bezahlen. Das ist durchaus ein kritischer Punkt. Und ich habe die Freude und die Ehre, Deutschland an diesem Tisch zu vertreten als der Delegationsleiter der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Deutschland und Frankreich sind ja die am stärksten vertretenen Organisationen. Da spielt das auch historisch, glaube ich, schon auch immer eine große Rolle. Italien ist noch sehr stark, dann gibt es viele andere Mitgliedsländer. Aber die Assoziation anderer Länder findet ja auch statt. Und das geht ja auch dann sehr weit in den Osten und auch, ich glaube, sogar bis Kanada, richtig? Das heißt, die ESA ist eigentlich schon sehr viel internationaler aufgestellt, als das E im Namen vermuten lassen könnte, oder?
Innerhalb der ESA sind die beiden stärksten Länder, was die finanzielle Beteiligung angeht, ganz klar Frankreich und Deutschland. In der Vergangenheit war meistens Frankreich der stärkere Beitragszahler. Im Moment ist es ganz kurzfristig mal Deutschland. Das wird sich aber wahrscheinlich wieder ändern. Warum sind die Beiträge überhaupt unterschiedlich? Es gibt bei der ESA einen Schlüssel, wie man die Beiträge bezahlt. Das eine ist zunächst erst mal nach dem entsprechenden Wirtschaftskraft des jeweiligen Landes ausgerichtet. Das ist ein Grundbeitrag. Dann kann man sich in sogenannten optionalen Programmen besonders interessiert zeigen und sagen, dieses Programm wollen wir zu 50 Prozent unserer Mittel reinstecken oder so etwas. Deshalb sind dann am Schluss zwei Länder, in dem Fall Frankreich und Deutschland, mit Abstand die beiden Hauptbeitragszahler. Daher kommt, warum das überhaupt unterschiedlich ist. Die ESA ist eine europäische Weltraumagentur. Deshalb alle 18 Mitgliedsländer sind europäische Staaten. Sie sind nicht automatisch Mitglied der EU, also zum Beispiel Schweiz und Norwegen sind auch Mitgliedsstaaten der ESA. Die ESA ist eine Intergovernmental Organization. Das heißt, sie ist eine Organisation, die einen legalen Status hat, der eben über den nationalen Staaten hinausreicht. Eine Intergovernmental Organization, ein sehr hoher Rang, den man dort erreicht hat. Jetzt hier hatten Kanada erwähnt. Kanada ist ein assoziiertes Mitglied, also kein Vollmitglied im herkömmlichen Sinn, was ich durchaus bedauere, weil nämlich die kanadischen Interessen und die deutschen Interessen sich häufig treffen. Aber sie sind ein assoziiertes Mitglied mit ein paar weniger Rechten als ein Vollmitglied und manchmal auch mit für mich nicht ganz nachvollziehbaren Schwierigkeiten bei der Umsetzung von Projekten, bei denen es dann heiß sah, es muss aber doch europäisch sein. Ich glaube, dass die Welt sich dort verändert. Wir werden in Zukunft noch viel globaler denken und insofern freue ich mich immer, denn gerade mit Kanada, ich nannte Innoviq haben wir beste Beziehung.
Das heißt, es ist durchaus denkbar, wenn vielleicht auch nicht unmittelbar absehbar, dass die ESA sich zum wirklichen internationalen Gebilde auch weiterentwickelt?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also zunächst erstmal ist die Entwicklung der ESA in Europa ein zentraler Punkt und da haben wir auch noch ein bisschen an Hausaufgaben zu machen. Die EU beansprucht für sich selber auch eine Rolle in der Raumfahrt. Ich persönlich, und das ist nicht nur meine persönliche Meinung, sondern es ist die Meinung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, der Bundesregierung. Wir stehen ganz klar für eine starke ESA in Europa. Wir sagen, die ESA ist die europäische Weltraumagentur, was nicht heißt, dass es nicht auch nationale Agenturen geben darf. Ganz im Gegenteil, Raumfahrt hat eine besondere Struktur. Die Raumfahrtindustrie ist nicht eine Wettbewerbsstruktur wie die Automobilindustrie, wo sie zwischen vielen, was weiß ich, 20, 30 Autoherstellern unterscheiden können und sich im Wettbewerb aussuchen können, wer das schönste Auto nach ihren Ansprüchen macht. Die Raumfahrtindustrie ist sehr monopolistisch aufgebaut. Es gibt starke Player hier, starke Player da. Und über das spezielle Instrument der ESA, das nennen wir dann auch den geografischen Rückfluss. Das heißt nämlich, wenn wir für ein Projekt 50 Prozent Mittel bezahlen, dann haben wir auch einen Anspruch, dass 50 Prozent der Aufträge, die nach außen gehen, dann wieder nach Deutschland gehen. Über dieses Instrument machen wir Industriepolitik über die ESA. Europäische und nationale Industriepolitik. Und deshalb glaube ich, dass dieses Instrument ESA auch für die Zukunft das Modell ist, mit dem wir weiter arbeiten müssen und arbeiten sollten. Und wir sollten gucken, welche Aufgaben die EU in der Raumfahrt einnehmen kann. Aber ich sehe schon, dass wir für Europa genug genügend Aufgaben haben und nicht überall gleich die Weltformel entdecken müssen.
Aber es gibt eine starke Raumfahrt, Forschungs- und Betriebsinfrastruktur in Europa. Das kann man schon mal festhalten.
Ja.
Mit starken Zentren wahrscheinlich in Deutschland und in Frankreich, aber auch in anderen Ländern. Und das sind alle die, die bei der ESA beteiligt sind?
Wir haben es geschafft, wenn ich jetzt sage wir, dann ist das nicht mein Verdienst, weil ich erst drei Jahre dabei bin. Aber Europa hat es geschafft, eine starke Raumfahrtstruktur aufzubauen. Und zwar länderübergreifend. Wir haben in der ESA, die ESA selbst, das Headquarter sitzt in Paris. Aber die ESA hat auch Zentren in den verschiedenen Ländern. Also in Deutschland haben wir das Europäische Astronauten-Ausbildungszentrum hier in Köln. Und wir haben das Europäische Saladitten-Kontrollzentrum in Darmstadt. Also wir haben zwei ESA-Einrichtungen in Deutschland, zwei große. Und ähnliche Sachen gibt es dann noch in Italien. Da gibt es Esren in der Nähe von Rom, wo insbesondere die Erdbeobachtung der ESA vorangetrieben wird. Und so weiter. Es gibt verschiedene Aktivitäten. Wir haben es geschafft, Strukturen aufzubauen und Kompetenzen aufzubauen, gerade auch in der Abstimmung mit den Mitgliedstaaten. Also in der ESA-Konvention wird ausdrücklich hervorgehoben, dass die ESA nicht einfach für sich alleine arbeiten soll und alles selber aufbauen soll, sondern es soll immer auf die Kompetenzen der Länder zurückgreifen. Also das DLR hat auch ein Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum in Oberpfaffenhofen. Und das arbeitet auch für die ESA, setzt also die Kompetenzen für die ESA ein. Das Kolumbus-Kontrollzentrum für das Europäische Forschungsmodul Kolumbus ist im DLR in Oberpfaffenhofen. Und so arbeitet Europa. Wir führen zusammen, wir führen die Kompetenzen zusammen und haben auch etwas ganz besonderes, nämlich das Raketen-Startgelände in Kourou, den europäischen Weltraumbahnhof, der noch nicht mal auf unserem Kontinent ist. Der ist in Französisch-Gruyana in Südamerika ganz dicht am Äquator. Das ist eine Lage. Der Äquator ist für Satelliten-Staats die beste Position, weil man vom Äquator aus jeden beliebigen Orbit, jede beliebigen Umlaufbahn um die Erde ansteuern kann. Sie können eine Bahn wählen, die genau um den Äquator drum herum fließt. Sie können aber auch eine Bahn wählen, die über die Pole geht. Das geht gerade vom Äquator aus optimal, während man von allen anderen Standorten aus wesentlich mehr Energie einsetzen muss, um verschiedene Bahnen zu erreichen. Und deshalb sind wir sehr froh, dass es diese Möglichkeit gibt, über die französische Verbindung nach Französisch-Guiana, eben dort einen europäischen Weltraumbahnhof nutzen zu können.
Die, vielleicht nochmal kurz, bevor ich dann auch wirklich voll auf Raumfahrt einsteigen möchte, aber um auch nochmal diese Sonderrolle des DLR zu verstehen, wir hatten ja schon angesprochen, Luftfahrtforschung spielt eine große Rolle, Energieforschung, viele Disziplinen, die jetzt hier von den Forschern wahrgenommen werden. Es gab ja vor kurzem einen Sonderfall mit diesem Vulkanausbruch in Island, Eiafjalla, genau, der Name, den ich hier sicher gut aussprechen kann. Ich habe jetzt auch vorher nicht geübt, was ja dann so eine Sondersituation war. Und da spielte ja das DLR dann auf einmal auch eine besondere Rolle, indem sozusagen die Situation dann auch vom DLR untersucht wurde. Ist das sozusagen eine regelmäßige Aufgabe des DLR, in solchen Momenten auch einzustehen, was ist da passiert?
Also wir sind bei solchen Krisensituationen immer aktiv. Ob das Überschwemmungen sind, ob das Erdbeben sind, ob das Waldbrände sind, alles haben wir in den letzten Monaten erlebt oder erleben es leider im Moment noch immer noch, das DLR ist immer mit seinen Kompetenzen aktiv. Wie macht es das? Ich will es am Beispiel Eiaferra Jökull, also diesem Vulkan auf dem isländischen Gletscher, erläutern. Dort ist ja die Situation gewesen, dass ein Vulkan ausgebrochen ist. Ein Vulkanausbruch ist nun etwas, was in besonderer Weise auch Auswirkungen dann zeigt. Und das Erste ist, man muss vor Ort gucken, was ist vor Ort passiert. Das geht nicht so ohne weiter. Sie können da nicht mit einem Flugzeug in die Vulkanwolke hineinfliegen, unmittelbar beim Vulkan. Das funktioniert nicht. Da haben wir die Satelliten benutzt. Wir haben mit Satellitenbildern in den Vulkan hineingeschaut und zwar mit einer Radartechnologie, bei der Deutschland führend ist, können wir nämlich auch durch die ganzen Wolken durchgucken. Also direkt in den Krater auch hineingeschaut. Auf der Basis dieser Informationen wussten wir, was uns da alles so bevorsteht und haben unser Flugzeug möglichst rasch flugfähig gemacht. Ein Flugzeug, eine Falcon, die jetzt ausgestattet wurde mit den Messgeräten, um in der Atmosphäre die Konzentration der Vulkanasche messen zu können.
Was haben dir diese Radarbilder sozusagen ergeben?
Wir haben erst mal gezeigt, wie groß das Ausmaß der Öffnung des Vulkans ist nach oben. Drei riesen Öffnungen, die dieser Vulkan nach oben hatte, der Vulkankrater, der also zeigte, hier ist wirklich, hier wird einiges kommen. Und das kam ja dann auch so.
Also sozusagen, um die Dimension überhaupt dieser Aschewolke einschätzen zu können.
Und außerdem konnten wir auch mit Bildern aus, mit Satellitenbildern die erste Bewegung der Aschewolke auch nachvollziehen, wo bewegt sie sich hin. Dann wurden Rechenmodelle angestellt, weil dann ist die Asche so verteilt, dass sie sich nicht mehr ohne Weiteres in einem optischen Bild eines Satelliten sehen können. Also das ist dann nicht mehr so, dass da eine schwarze Fahne ist, sondern das ist dann eine erhöhte Aschekonzentration, die nicht mehr unmittelbar dem menschlichen Auge direkt überall zugänglich ist. Und dafür haben wir dann eben unser Flugzeug, unsere Falcon ausgerüstet. Wir mussten dazu, weil die Falcon gerade für eine ganz andere Messkampagne unterwegs war, mussten wir sie entsprechend leer machen, mussten die entsprechenden Geräte einbauen, ein zentrales Instrument dabei ist ein LIDAR, LIDAR, der Name kommt, da steckt zwei Sachen drin, da steckt einmal Radar drin, das kennt man so ein bisschen. Und das L steht für Light, also für Licht, in dem Fall für Laser. Das heißt, mit einem Laserradar konnte dann, indem man über die Wolke drüber wegfliegt, nach unten geguckt werden und konnte die Konzentration dieser Aschewolke gemessen werden. Zusätzlich wurden noch Proben entnommen, um also zu sehen, welche genaue chemische Zusammensetzungen haben wir da, wie viel Schwefelanteil usw. Und mit diesen Flügen, die wir dann durchgeführt haben, über der Bundesrepublik, wir sind aber übrigens auch bis Island hinaufgeflogen, um auch zu gucken, wie groß ist die Quelle dort an, was, wie viel kommt da wirklich jetzt heraus, wie viel Aschewolke, um da genaue Informationen zu sammeln. Und auf der Basis unserer Messflüge konnte dann übrigens auch die Freigabe wieder erfolgen, dass man wieder nach einigen Tagen den Flugverkehr wieder freigeben konnte.
Das heißt, es war eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlimm?
Doch, nein, nein. Nur es musste ja weiter gemessen werden. In den ersten Tagen war die Konzentration sehr hoch. Die Frage war übrigens auch noch, welche sind die Grenzwerte? Da mussten wir unsere Luftfahrer und unsere Triebwerksleute mit ransetzen. Das haben wir dann eine Arbeitsgruppe eingerichtet, mit dem Verkehrsministerium gemeinsam umzuentwickeln, mit welchen Grenzwerten wir überhaupt fliegen dürfen. Interessanterweise waren diese Daten nicht vorhanden, aber sie wurden dann entwickelt. Wir sind dann mehrfach geflogen. Der erste Flug war drei Tage nachdem die Aschewolke hier angekommen war. Da waren tatsächlich noch lokal Werte da, die dieses Flugverbot auch rechtfertigten. Aber dann sind wir nochmal geflogen, um zu gucken, ist es jetzt auch wirklich so, dass man sagen kann, jetzt ist die Situation bereinigt und dadurch konnte dann auch der Flugverkehr wieder freigegeben.
Also, um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, die Bedrohung war ja, dass durch diese Asche die Triebwerke der Flugzeuge nicht beschädigt werden oder außer Betrieb gesetzt werden.
Es gibt mehrere Bedrohungen, die da ausgesprochen wurden. Die einfachste Bedrohung ist noch, dass die Scheiben des Cockpits matt werden. Das ist noch die einfachste, in Anführungsstrichen, die man direkt sehen könnte. Die große Bedrohung ist tatsächlich, dass Triebwerke dabei nicht nur irgendwie beschädigt werden können, sondern tatsächlich auch ausfahren können. Es gab mehrere Erfahrungen von Flügen, insbesondere auch in Indonesien, bei denen sogar eine Boeing 747 komplett alle Triebwerke ausgefallen war. Zum Glück sind sie wieder angesprungen. Aber dieses Thema wollten wir genauer angucken. Es gibt mehrere Risiken innerhalb des Triebwerks. Das eine ist, wenn der Sauerstoffgehalt nicht hoch genug ist, dann geht es einfach raus. Kann passieren. Das ist schon ein ziemlicher Schritt, bis man dahin kommt. Ansonsten können diese Staubpartikel schmelzen in dem Triebwerk und können sich verkleben, können also dort Beschädigungen herbeiführen. Diese Turbinenblätter, die dort in dem Triebwerk drin sind, die sind von innen mit Luft gekühlt. Die haben ganz feine Öffnungen, durch die Luft durchgeblasen wird, durch die Blätter durch und die können natürlich schnell verstopfen oder verkleben. Und dann gibt es noch mehrere andere Korrosionseffekte. Durch den hohen Schwefelanteil kann es noch Korrosionseffekte geben. Also es gibt eine ganze Palette von möglichen Schädigungen, die übrigens auch anders sind als bei einem Saharasand oder so. Also gerade Vulkanasche zeigt dann nochmal eine besondere Situation, hoher Schwefelgehalt und andere Dinge, anderer Schmelzpunkt. Und deshalb war es wichtig, das genau zu untersuchen.
Was war denn das für eine Erfahrung? Weil für mich wirkt das jetzt so ein bisschen wie so ein Feuerwehreinsatz. Vor allem die Feuerwehr hat ja auch mal das Problem, dass sie eigentlich auch erst in dem Moment, wo der Alarm kommt, genau weiß, worum handelt es sich. Man muss in gewisser Hinsicht ja eigentlich für jeden Fall gerüstet sein, aber am Ende ist dann jeder Fall auch wieder anders. Neben der Forschung und dem langfristigen Plan von Projekten, da schießt man mal in 20 Jahren dann eine Sonde los und die fliegt dann auch nochmal zehn. Das sind ja ganz andere Dimensionen. Was entwickelt das für eine Dynamik für so eine Organisation?
Also besser als sie die Frage stellt, dann kann ich auch die Antwort nicht geben. Sie haben vollkommen recht. Die Frage stellen wir uns auch. Welche Dynamik kommt daraus? Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel einen ganz anderen Fall annehmen, noch mal kurz beschreiben, Haiti, das Erdbeben in Haiti. Wir standen vor der Frage, hier ist ein katastrophales Erdbeben. Es ist in einer Region passiert, in der die Infrastruktur darauf überhaupt nicht vorbereitet war. Was können wir tun? Was haben wir getan? Wir haben aus dem Weltall heraus die Struktur aufgenommen. Wir haben auf der einen Seite wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse gewonnen, welche Verformungen sind entstanden, wo ist der Erdbeben im Herd und so weiter. Das will ich jetzt mal außen vor lassen. Ich will jetzt mehr auf die humanitäre Seite gucken. Wir haben aus dem Weltall heraus den Zerstörungsgrad der Städte in Karten umgebaut. Das heißt, wir haben aus dem Weltall geguckt und haben dann die Informationen gegeben.
Gekuckt, jetzt optisch geguckt?
Optisch geguckt, optisch. Und haben geguckt, wie zerstört sind die Gebäude und haben das in Karten eingetragen, sodass sie eine Karte bekommen haben. Und da wussten sie, in diesem Stadtviertel sind mehr als 40 Prozent aller Gebäude zerstört oder es sind weniger als zehn Prozent aller Gebäude zerstört. Dieses Kartenmaterial haben wir dann den Verantwortlichen vor Ort zugeschickt, elektronisch. Dadurch wussten die sofort, wo ist hier wirklich die Priorität eins zu setzen. Die Priorität eins ist jetzt sehr schön, aber sie müssen den nächsten Weg, das nächste Wissen, sie müssen wissen, wie komme ich da hin und was kann ich mit den Leuten dort, wo kann ich die denn, wenn die verletzt sind, wo kann ich sie hinbringen. Und deshalb haben wir ein zweites Set von Kartenmaterial geliefert, in dem die noch befahrbaren Straßen und Wege und die nächsten Rettungsstationen enthalten waren. Und auch das haben wir elektronisch übermittelt. Das heißt, wir haben hier wirklich für die Krisensituation Datenmaterial geliefert, was dann vor Ort ausgewertet schon, schon ausgewertet war, aber vor Ort dann benutzt werden konnte. Wir nennen das diesen Bereich innerhalb des DLRs, das Zentrum für Satelliten gestützte Kriseninformationen.
Wie zuverlässig sind denn diese Daten, die die Satelliten, ich meine, das sind ja sehr zuverlässig.
Die sind, ja, das sind Bilder. Und diese Bilder werden ausgewertet. Das ist dann auch, weil sie gesagt haben, wie genau weiß man eigentlich vorher, was man hinterher machen muss. Also in dem Fall musste da auch sehr viel händisch gemacht werden, auf die Gebäude geguckt werden und dann entschieden werden.
Also wenn jetzt schon davon ist, dass Leute sich wirklich die Karten angeguckt haben und es ausgewertet haben, okay, ich dachte man könnte vielleicht auch schon automatisieren.
Das kann man auch, das kann man auch, aber in diesem Fall haben wir es so gemacht, in einem Raster von 250 x 250 Meter, das ist ein sehr kleines Raster, wenn sie aus dem Weltall gucken, haben wir dann die Informationen gemacht. Oder jetzt bei den Waldbränden in Russland war die Aufgabenstellung natürlich eine ganz andere. Da mussten wir gucken, wo fließt, wo geht, wo geht das Feuer hin, was, was kann man aus dem Weltall an Unterstützung bieten. Oder die Überschwemmung, ja auch das Thema. Tsunami in damals in Indonesien, auch das Thema ist aus dem Weltall untersucht worden.
Neben dieser Feuerwehr-Tätigkeit steht natürlich die Forschung im Vordergrund.
Ich würde nicht nur sagen nehmen, sondern das beeinflusst sich gegenseitig. Also nur dadurch, dass wir die hochwertige Forschung machen, haben wir auch morgen die Flexibilität, auf eine neue Situation ganz schnell zu reagieren, zu sagen, wir haben doch unseren Radar-Satelliten oder wir haben unseren Infrarot-Satelliten oder wir haben die Möglichkeit, optische Satelliten die Daten zu nutzen. Also die Forschung befruchtet diese Kriseninformationen und umgekehrt aus dem Ergebnis, aus dem AFR Jökull, wissen wir genau, auf was wir jetzt eigentlich forschungsmäßig und besser vorbereiten müssen. In der Frage der Triebwerksbeschädigung, in der Frage der Beobachtung aus dem Weltall, was können wir da anbieten? Also die beiden befruchten sich und deshalb dürfen die auch nicht getrennt sein. Die müssen ganz dicht zusammen sein, nicht neben. Das wollte ich damit nur noch mal intervenieren.
Ich wollte jetzt noch mal den Bogen aber wieder zur Raumfahrt spannen und vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen mehr noch in die Vergangenheit gehen. Jetzt nicht unbedingt wieder zurück bis zum Sputnik, aber der Staat, der, wie soll ich sagen, dieses europäischen Raumfahrt-Projekte, was ja auch, sagen wir mal, finde ich zumindest für Europa auch sehr profilbildend ist, dass man eben einfach selbst auch der eigenen Namen dort voranschreitet. Was waren denn so die wichtigsten Projekte, die jetzt diese europäische Entwicklung auch wirklich getragen haben? Also ich denke, was jeder kennt, das sind so die Ariane-Trägerraketen in dem bereits genannten Standort in Kow. Ariane 1 war, glaube ich, 1979, die gestartet ist. Was hat das bewirkt? Wie kam es dazu und was hat das für eine Auswirkung gehabt?
Also wir hatten ja auch noch die Europa-Rakete, wir hatten auch Staats- von Wumara in Australien. Also die Frage des autonomen Zugangs zum All. Das ist eine Frage, die politisch eine besondere Funktion hatte. Und diese Frage zu beantworten mit Ja und Ja, wir machen da etwas, war sicherlich eine politische Meisterleistung. Zu entscheiden, jawohl, Europa wird ein eigenen Zugang zum All durch Trägerraketen sicherstellen. Und die Entwicklung war manchmal wirklich schwierig und hatte auch einige Rückschläge, zum Beispiel auch bei der jetzigen Ariane 5. Die war ja ursprünglich geplant als Trägerrakete für die bemannte Raumfahrt mit dem Raumfahrtprojekt Hermes. Hermes sollte ein Raumkleider sein. Das Projekt war wirklich auch wieder eine politische Meisterleistung, so etwas auf den Weg zu bringen. Es ist gescheitert letztlich an ein paar Fragen, nicht nur finanzieller Art, sondern auch technischer Art zu dem Zeitpunkt. Aber überhaupt so einen politischen Mut zu haben, das bewundere ich auch im Nachhinein, dass man gesagt hat, wir wollen so etwas in Europa bauen. Und es ist eine Erfolgsgeschichte. Ariane 5 ist die zuverlässigste Rakete weltweit. Und sie ist auch eine Schwerlastrakete, die also Lasten bis hin zu dem ATV, dem Automated Transfer Vehicle, das 20 Tonnen wiegt, in die Umlaufbahn bringen kann. Also es ist eine fantastische Rakete. Natürlich kann auch morgen mal etwas passieren mit dieser Rakete. Das muss man auch immer in Kauf nehmen und auch berücksichtigen. Darf nicht glauben, dass es nur, weil es in der Vergangenheit funktioniert hat, funktioniert es in der Zukunft. Das sind hochtechnische Geräte, die auch ohne viele Sicherheitsmargen arbeiten müssen. Sonst würden sie nicht mehr fliegen. Wenn ich als Bauingenieur da eine anständige Beton-Rakete bauen würde, die würde ja nicht mehr fliegen, weil sie zu schwer wäre. Also insofern ist das Technik at its best. Es ist ganz weit vorne an der Front der Möglichkeiten. Und das war ein ganz wichtiger Schritt für Europa, an dieser Stelle zu zeigen, jawohl, Europa kann einen autonomen Zugang zum All gewährleisten. Aber Sie haben recht, es gab viele andere Projekte, Satellitenprojekte. Es gab Missionen zu anderen Planeten, zum Mars sind wir sehr erfolgreich aus Europa geflogen, mit Mars Express, zum Mond-Titan des Saturns, mit der Mission Cassini-Holgens, gemeinsam mit den Amerikanern. Eine sehr erfolgreiche europäische Mission. Also es gibt viele Missionen in der Vergangenheit, die auf diesem Weg alles Mögliche abgedeckt haben. Also einerseits diesen autonomen Zugang zum All sichergestellt haben und auch immer noch sicherstellen, zum anderen aber auch eine europäische Selbstständigkeit in anderen Bereichen. Aktuelles Thema zum Beispiel auch Galileo, das Navigationssystem.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz zur Ariane. Sie sagten ja, zuverlässigstes System. Woran macht man das fest?
An der Qualität der Staats, sowohl der Fehlstaats, die wirklich in der Ariane nur in der Anfangsphase überhaupt entstanden.
Der erste Flug war die Vollkatastrophe.
Sie müssen das so sehen, wenn Sie in anderen Bereichen der Produktentwicklung etwas machen, dann bis das Produkt wirklich auf dem Markt ist, sind die Produkte schon zigmal hergestellt. Hier muss die Rakete, wie sie zusammengebaut ist, muss fliegen. So ganz einfache Forderung. Und das kann dann zu Problemen führen. In dem Fall gab es ein paar Probleme, die im Nachhinein natürlich voraussehbar waren. Aber das ist ja das Spannende daran. Sie waren eben der Situation nicht erkannt. Es gab einen Übertragungsfehler von der Vorgängerrakete der Ariane 4 zur Ariane 5. Also das ist alles, finde ich, im Ingenieurbereich auch akzeptabel, solange man damit nicht Dinge gefährdet, wie Menschen leben. Da muss man halt aufpassen. Auch bei Raketen oder Trägern für Menschen, das haben wir die Erfahrung gemacht, ist wegen dieser geringen Sicherheitsmargen, die man am Schluss nur noch haben kann, natürlich auch immer Menschenleben in Gefahr. Wir wissen das von dem Space Shuttle, aber auch Apollo 1 sind ja die Astronauten verbrannt, oft am Boden verbrannt. Also das ist in diesem Bereich der Technik, wenn wir ganz weit nach vorne gehen, dann sind auch solche Opfer nicht ganz vermeidbar. Das schreckt den einen oder anderen ab und ich selber habe dann auch schon mal die Frage gekommen, ob ich denn bereit wäre, in einem solchen Fall mit der Witwe zu reden. Ich finde, das ist ein unredlicher Ansatz. Technik und Entwicklung der Gesellschaft muss natürlich, so weit es kann, auf Sicherheit gehen. Aber es muss auch gleichzeitig immer Möglichkeiten geben, ein Stück weiterzugehen als bisher. Und dann genau, wenn ich weitergehe als bisher, dann gehe ich in unerforschtes, dann gehe ich in Neuland und da können Sachen passieren. Columbus ist auch nicht mit allen Leuten zurückgekommen.
Ich denke, das macht auch den Reiz der gesamten Operation auch ein Stück weit aus.
Ich würde gerne auf den Reiz der Verluste verzichten. Aber zu überlegen im Vorhinein, habe ich alles bedacht. Das ist natürlich für einen Ingenieur ein Reiz. Und wenn wir dann so einen Satelliten wie den Satelliten Terraza X, einen solchen Satelliten gab es vorher nicht, einen Radarsatelliten mit ungeahnter Präzision. Wenn wir so einen Satelliten dann wirklich erfolgreich im Orbit haben und das jetzt schon einige Jahre, dann ist das ein Reiz, der einen dann auch befriedigt. Der darf einen nicht übermütig machen und glauben, wir kriegen jedes Projekt hin, das nächste Projekt kann auch wieder schief gehen.
Die Ariane hat jetzt schon so einiges nach oben befördert. Ein paar Namen sind ja jetzt schon auch schon gefallen, wie zum Beispiel das Columbus-Labor.
Nein, das Columbus-Modul ist mit dem Space Shuttle.
Ach so.
Aber ATV ist richtig.
In die falsche Richtung marschiert. Vielleicht aber ihr wollt trotzdem auf dieses Modul kommen. Das spielt ja auch eine große Rolle. Das ist ein Teil der ISS, die jeden Tag über unsere Köpfe hinwegfegt. Was ist der europäische Anteil daran?
Columbus ist das europäische Forschungslabor. Es ist eine komplette europäische Produktion. Es ist eine italienische Hülle. Und viel deutsches Innenleben. Die Hülle ist eine Konstruktion der Italiener. Sie ist dann aber in Bremen, da ist das Gesamtsystem zusammengebaut worden. Columbus ist ein Forschungsmodul. Es ist ein Forschungslabor, ein fliegendes Forschungslabor, in dem ganz verschiedene Forschung betrieben werden kann. Es ist an dem amerikanischen Teil der Internationalen Raumstation angedockt. Es ist mit einem Space Shuttle hochgeflogen worden, dann von Hans Schlegel, der ein Astronaut war, der dabei war, dann auch mit befestigt worden an der Internationalen Raumstation. Und es ist unsere Außenposten im All. Da vielleicht auch noch mal die Information. Außenposten und All und Weltall, das klingt immer so fern ab. Wir müssen feststellen, unsere Erde hat einen Durchmesser von 12.000 Kilometer. Und wenn sie auf den Mount Everest steigen, dann wird die Luft schon dünn. In 100 Kilometern fängt definitionsgemäß das Weltall an. Also nur 100 Kilometer oberhalb der Erde ist sozusagen schon nichts mehr mit normalem Leben. Durchmesser ist 12.000 Kilometer. Da merkt man, wie dünn die Schicht, die um die Erde ist, in der wir überhaupt leben können und wie empfindlich das System ist. Und die internationale Raumstation fliegt so in der Höhe von 350 bis 400 Kilometer über die Erde. Also relativ dicht, dichter als Köln und München. Und trotzdem ist das da oben eine Herausforderung, weil sie eben nicht mal sagen können, okay, da ist gerade mal was, ich gehe mal gerade ins Geschäft nebenan und besorge mir ein paar Ersatzteile. Wir hatten so eine Situation jetzt ja gerade, in dem ein Kühlsystem ausgefallen war. Und die Reparatur ist dann wirklich etwas Schwieriges. Nicht nur in der Frage der Schwerelosigkeit. Das hilft einem. Da kann man halt auch schwere Dinge leicht hin und her transportieren. Aber in dieser rauen Umgebung ohne Sauerstoff, dort also mit Außenbord einsetzen, die ich nicht gerne Weltraumspaziergänge nenne, weil sie wirklich sehr, sehr anstrengend sind, da so eine Reparatur durchzuführen. Auch noch mit einem giftigen Stoff, der für diese Kühlanlage nötig ist. Also das ist schon Technik wirklich ganz...
War das ein Defekt an den Columbus oder an der Anstelle dieses?
Nein, das war eine internationale Raumstation, war eine Kühlpumpe ausgefallen. Hatte nichts mit Columbus zu tun. Aber die Forschungsarbeiten mussten eingestellt werden für ein paar Tage, weil man einfach die Kühlleistungen auf ein Minimum reduzieren musste. Man hat ein redundantes, also ein zweites System gehabt, war keine Bedrohung. Das ist auch wieder so eine typische Raumfahrtaktivität. Wir versuchen immer, die Systeme, die wichtigen Systeme mehrfach einzubauen, sodass sie ruhig ausfallen können und die volle, möglichst die volle Leistungsfähigkeit da ist, weil es einfach zu gefährlich ist, wenn Menschen dabei sind, aber auch zu teuer, wenn es ein unbemanntes System ist.
Ja, einen Absturz kann man sich auch nicht leisten.
Nein, nicht so ohne weiteres. Also, wenn Sie so gucken, so eine Mission, so eine Terra-Sax-Mission, die kostet deutlich über 100 Millionen Euro, da können wir uns nicht erlauben, dass wir einfach sagen, okay, ist halt schiefgegangen. Das können wir uns nicht erlauben. Deshalb müssen die Systeme sicher sein. Und das gilt natürlich ganz besonders, wenn wir dann auch Menschen an Bord haben. Und Kolumbus ist das erste bemannte europäische Raumsystem gewesen. Ein System, in dem Menschen leben können. Und deshalb war Kolumbus und ist Kolumbus eine hervorragende Leistungsfähigkeit, zeigt hervorragend die Leistungsfähigkeit Europas. Und gleichzeitig ist es ein Modell für die Zukunft, in dem wir zusammen alles zusammengebracht haben, um dann nicht nur da oben eine nette Büchse rumfliegen zu lassen, sondern in dieser Büchse wirklich Forschung zu machen, die sonst nirgends geht. Und auch die Amerikaner nutzen unser Forschungslabor Kolumbus und die Russen auch.
Das andere Projekt, was Sie erwähnten, ATV, Automated Transfer Vehicle, was verbirgt sich dahinter? Das war das Schwere, oder?
Das ist 20 Tonnen, das wiegt etwa 20 Tonnen. Das ist ein Transportraumschiff. Es dient dazu, Versorgungsgüter zur Internationalen Raumstation zu bringen. Dort muss frisches Wasser, Lebensmittel, Treibstoff und so weiter hingebracht werden. Dieses Automated Transfer Vehicle ist wiederum eine europäische gemeinsame Konstruktion von den Franzosen entwickelt, jetzt im Moment gebaut von deutschen Unternehmen wiederum in Bremen. Dieses Automated Transfer Vehicle, wie der Name schon sagt, ist automated, das heißt automatisch, es wurde gestartet mit einer IANA-5 und findet dann automatisch die International-Raumstation ohne, dass jemand an Bord ist und dockt auch automatisch an die International-Raumstation an mit einer Laser-Navigation, örtlichen Laser-Navigation, also komplett automatisch und das klingt so trivial, aber man muss überlegen, diese International-Raumstation fliegt mit einer Geschwindigkeit von 28.000 Kilometer pro Stunde um die Erde, und da soll jetzt ganz vorsichtig angedockt werden, denn in der International-Raumstation sind Menschen, zwar sind in dem ATV keine Menschen, aber das ATV darf jetzt nicht einfach dagegen donnern und die International-Raumstation beschädigen und deshalb ist auch dieses ein Beispiel für Hochtechnologie made in Europe.
Mit 20 Tonnen kann man das Ding schon ganz gut pulverisieren, wenn man an ihm haut.
Selbst wenn sie nur mit 10 Stundenkilometer einen Lastwagen mit 20 Tonnen, wenn der einfach gegen eine ganz weiche, fragile Struktur, das ist ja da oben alles leicht und weich, dagegen donnern würde, das ist nicht akzeptabel. Es muss also zentimetergenau angedockt werden. Das hat auf Anhieb funktioniert mit dem ersten ATV, das trug den Namen Jules Verne. Jetzt wird das zweite ATV noch dieses Jahr gestartet, das wird den Namen haben Johannes Kepler, einen großen Astronomen und wir hoffen natürlich, dass auch wieder alles genauso gut und perfekt geht. Neben dieser Funktion, das fliegt nur einmal, das wollte ich gerade erklären, das fliegt also hin, bringt die ganzen Materialien hin und wenn es dann seinen Dienstwart erstmal diese Transportleistung erbracht hat, hat es noch eine zweite Funktion, selbst in der Höhe von 350 Kilometern über der Erde, gibt es noch Spuren von Atmosphäre. Das heißt, die International-Raumstation wird langsam abgebremst und durch die Abbremsung nähert sich der Erde und würde dann, wenn man nichts macht, verglühen. Deshalb muss die International-Raumstation immer wieder beschleunigt werden, wieder auf einen höheren Orbit gebracht werden und das macht auch das Automated Transfer Vehicle. Das ATV hat also die Möglichkeit, die International-Raumstation wieder zu beschleunigen, auf einen höheren Orbit zu bringen. Das schubst sie sozusagen an. Und wenn das auch noch alles erfolgt ist, dann wird alles das, was man nicht mehr braucht, auf der ISS in dieses Automated Transfer Vehicle getan. Nicht einfach rausgeworfen, sondern in das Automated Transfer Vehicle. Und dann wird es gezielt zum Absturz in die Erdatmosphäre gebracht und verglüht dann in der Erdatmosphäre über einem Bereich, wo dann auch keine Menschen sind, um falls doch noch irgendwelche Trümmer bis zur Erdoberfläche kommen sollten, dass niemand gefährdet wird. Also diese Funktion hat das ATV. Derzeit wird überlegt, ob man das ATV ein Stück weiter entwickeln kann, nämlich dass es einen Teil dann auch wieder zur Erde ganz gezielt zurückbringen kann, eine Rückkehrfähigkeit. Denn viele der Experimente, die an Bord der Internationalen Raumstation gemacht werden, sollten wieder zur Erde zurückgebracht werden. Dafür wird es ab nächsten Jahr fast keine Möglichkeiten mehr geben. Das Space Shuttle wird eingestellt. Letzter Flug im Moment geplant für den 26. Februar 2011. Und in der russischen Soyuz-Kapsel kann man nur sehr begrenzt wieder Material mit zur Erde bringen, sodass ab nächsten Jahr keine Rückkehrmöglichkeit da ist. Und deshalb wird im Moment in der ESA ein Projekt vorangebracht, zu überlegen, dieses ATV mit einer rückkehrfähigen Kapsel auszustatten, um dann wenigstens Teile gezielt wieder zur Erde zurückzubringen.
Ist das so schwierig? Ich meine, schon die allerersten Dinge, die so hoch gingen, kamen ja eigentlich alle wieder.
Ja, aber sie brauchen schon die Technologie. Sie müssen einen anständigen Hitzeschild haben. Da hat das DLR hervorragende Kompetenz. Wir haben gerade was, dem Bereich von Wiedereintrittskörpern ist das DLR im Moment weltweit hoch beachtet. Wir haben ganz neue Technologien mit neuen Materialien. Aber es gehört schon richtig Geld dazu, so ein System zu entwickeln. Das wird ja auch nicht einfach rausgeworfen. Und gucken wir mal, wo es hinkommt. Das muss gesteuert werden. Sie sagen jetzt natürlich Apollo, Mercury und Gemini. Die haben das auch schon alles gekonnt. Trotzdem, die Technologie ist sehr anspruchsvoll. Wenn wir so viel Geld hätten, wie damals die Amerikaner Verfügung gestellt hätten, wäre es auch Ruckzuck gemacht.
Was ich da so interessant dran finde, ist, dass man sich bei komplexen Projekten wie der ISS eigentlich gar nicht so richtig klar macht, was eigentlich alles dazugehört, um so ein Projekt dann auch aufrechtzuerhalten. Versorgungskapsel, da denkt man vielleicht erstmal auch gar nicht dran, dass natürlich am laufenden Meter, was weiß ich, wenn es nur so was Banales ist, wie Nahrung hochgebracht werden muss. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich eine große Zahl unterschiedlicher Technologien, die sozusagen für diese Basisversorgung herangezogen werden, die teilweise vom DLR gemacht werden, teilweise von anderen Gruppen. Und wenn man jetzt sieht, dass der Space Shuttle, was ja sozusagen immer so dieses in allen Köpfen fest installierte Bild ist, mit das stellt die Verbindung zum Weltall her. Das wird jetzt irgendwie eingestellt. Stellt sich natürlich gleich die Frage, ist das dann auch so ein genereller Umbruch in der Raumfahrt-Technologie, dass man irgendwie weggeht von diesen großen, riesen Megatransportern hin zu einer sehr viel feingliederigen Verkehrstechnik, die sich da abspielt?
Diese Frage stellt sich natürlich gerade, wenn man jetzt erlebt, dass das Spaceshuttle eingestellt wird. Ich glaube, dass erst durch die internationale Raumstation diese Frage sich so richtig stellt. Als wir damals beobachtet haben, wie die Amerikaner Mercury, Gemini, Apollo und dann das Shuttle entwickelt haben, da hat sich die Frage interessanterweise ja nie gestellt. Natürlich gab es auch damals Pausen zwischen den verschiedenen Instrumenten, die man brauchte, um mit den Finanzmitteln, die immer begrenzt sind, das nächste System zu entwickeln. Also gerade zwischen Apollo und Shuttle. Da war eine lange Pause. Das merken wir nur heute, weil wir heute diese Pause irgendwie überbrücken müssen wegen der internationalen Raumstation. Damals ist dann halt auch keiner geflogen während der Zeit. Punkt. Tatsächlich kann man die Frage stellen, ob Shuttle die richtige Antwort zur richtigen Zeit war. Es war ein geniales Konzept, einen wiederverwendbaren Raumkleider zu bauen, der in der Lage ist, auf dem Land zu landen, nicht irgendwo im Wasser nur, sondern auf dem Land, der in der Lage ist, Astronauten und Material zu transportieren. Da wir aber für Astronauten ein wesentlich höheres Sicherheitsniveau verlangen, als einfach nur für einen Materialtransport, haben wir letztlich auch für die Tonnen, die an Material transportiert wurden, im Shuttle das Geld bezahlt, als wären das alles Astronauten. Also nicht wir, Amerikaner, aber deshalb ist von der Logik Ihre Frage glaube ich sehr verständlich. Ist es vernünftig, so ein Multipurpose-Raumschiff zu haben? Oder zahlt man da nicht sozusagen für das schwächste Glied oder das wichtigste Glied in der Kette zahlt man alles? Die Zukunft wird sicherlich im Moment erst mal so sein, dass man das stärker voneinander trennt, den Transport von Menschen und den Transport von Material. Das ist auch das, was in dem sogenannten Constellation-Programm der Amerikaner, das jetzt ja stark modifiziert wird, angedacht war. Da hatte man einen Träger und eine Transporteinheit für Material vorgesehen und eine für Personen und wollte dann im Earth Orbit die Sachen erst zusammenfügen. Das ist sicherlich ein Konzept, was für die nächsten Jahrzehnte das richtige Konzept sein wird. Gleichwohl will ich sagen, einen Raumkleider, einen wiederverwendbaren Raumkleider für den Transport von Material und Menschen, das ist schon eine Vision, die sehr, sehr weit in die Zukunft reicht. Ich bin sicher, dass die irgendwann auch wiederkommt. Ich glaube nicht, ich bin erst mal davon überzeugt, dass bemannte Raumfahrt auch noch in 100, 200, 300 Jahren existent sein wird, mit verschiedenen Zielen. Dann wird man sicherlich auch solche integrierenden Lösungen auch wieder bauen, aber vielleicht auf einem anderen Niveau, als das in der Vergangenheit ist. Das Shuttle ist einfach sehr, sehr teuer geworden durch diese verschiedenen Anforderungen.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass die bemannte Raumfahrt sein muss, allein schon, weil die Science-Fiction das vorgibt.
Ich glaube, dass es im Wesen des Menschen ist. Man kann das jetzt ja natürlich ganz rational angehen und sagen, wir brauchen nur bemannte Raumfahrt, solange wir nicht das alles mit Robotik können. Aber der Mensch wird es sich nicht nehmen lassen, auch dort persönlich hinzugehen, auf den Mars zu legen und den Fuß auf den Mars zu setzen. Das wird noch Jahrzehnte dauern, aber er wird es machen. Und ich brauche da jetzt gar nicht irgendwelche dramatischen Szenarien zu entwickeln mit Klimawandel und so, dass wir hier weggehen müssen. Das brauche ich nicht. Ich persönlich bin einfach jenseits aller rationalen Logik davon überzeugt, der Mensch lässt es sich nicht nehmen, da auch hinzugehen, wo er bisher nicht war. Er geht in die Tiefsee. Warum ist Jacques Picard in den Mariannengraben abgetaucht? Der hatte da unten nichts zu suchen. Das hätte ein Roboter genauso machen können. Warum sind Leute auf den Mount Everest geklettert? Das ist da oben wirklich nicht da oben. Man kommt leicht zu Schaden. Es ist eigentlich kein rationaler Grund dahinter. Leute machen es weiterhin. Natürlich müssen wir ein bisschen anders noch aufpassen, weil wir hier Steuermittel ausgeben. Aber ich glaube, das bemannte Raumfahrt wird es immer geben.
To boldly go where no man has gone before. Exactly. Die Vision, den Mars zu besuchen, die ist ja auch ganz konkret. Es gibt da ja auch ein Projekt, die Bedingungen dafür auszutesten.
Es gibt ein sogenanntes Mars 500 Projekt. Das ist von den Russen vorangetrieben worden. Die ESA ist dabei, das DLR unterstützt es auch. Da geht es um die Frage, um viele Fragen. Es geht um die Frage, diese Herausforderungen, wenn man zum Mars fliegen würde, sind schon gewaltig. Wenn wir zum Mond fliegen, dann können wir in einer Woche hin und zurück fliegen. Wenn ich Zahnschmerzen unterkriege, sage ich, ich kriege nächste Woche erst einen Termin beim Zahnarzt. Wenn ich zum Mars fliege und ich kriege am vierten Tag eine Blinddarmentzündung, dann kann ich nicht sagen, ich haue mir ein paar Medikamente rein, in drei Tagen bin ich zurück. Ich werde zum Mars hin und zurück mit unseren heutigen Technologien 1,5, 2 Jahre brauchen. So, das liegt auch ein bisschen daran, der Mars hat eine Umrundungszeit um die Sonne von zwei Jahren die Erde, wie wir alle wissen, von einem Jahr. Das heißt, die treffen sich nur alle zwei Jahre. Wenn man also nicht mit ganz anderen Technologien viel größere Entfernung viel schneller überbrücken kann, dann wird man so lange brauchen. Und deshalb ist diese Herausforderung alleine schon aus medizinischer Sicht eine Besondere. Es geht aber auch die psychologischen Aspekte, die Strahlungsaspekte und viele andere Fragen. Man kann auf dem Weg zum Mars nicht umdrehen. Wenn man hinfliegt, muss man hinfliegen und dann erst wieder zurückfliegen. Das geht nicht. Contipos Apollo 13 konnte ja auch nicht umdrehen und sagen, wir fliegen zurück. Die mussten um den Mond drum herum und wieder zurückkommen. Das ist einfach die Himmelsmechanik, die Planetenmechanik. Also das geht nicht. Und deshalb ist dieses Projekt Mars 500 natürlich so ein bisschen diese Perspektive, zum Mars zu fliegen. Da kann man jetzt sagen, okay, warum fangen die jetzt schon an, wenn wir erst in 30 Jahren da vielleicht hinfliegen? Aber es ist so, dass dieses Mars 500-Projekt auch jetzt schon Ergebnisse erreicht hat. Das heißt also, aus dieser Studie hat man medizinische Schlussfolgerungen ziehen können, auch die für den Menschen auf der Erde wirken. Es ist nicht so, dass das nur jetzt für Astronauten da ist. Wir wissen aus der Schwerelosigkeitsforschung, wissen wir viel, was im menschlichen Körper passiert mit Kreislaufbedingungen, mit Blutdruck, mit Knochenauf- und Abbau, mit Immunsystem und so weiter. Und so ähnlich ist es auch bei diesen Extremisolationsversuchen, die Mars 500, 500 Tage in einem eingeschlossenen Behälter in Moskau. Menschen, 500 Tage, ja.
Wie viele sind das? Sechs oder so, ne?
Ja, und ein Teil von denen wird dann nochmal abgetrennt, die den Abstieg auf den Mars machen. Also das wird echt simuliert. Und die kriegen auch während dieser 500 Tage verschiedene Szenarien vorgespielt. Da sagt man jetzt natürlich, das ist alles kein Problem. Die gehen raus aus der Hütte und das ist die Sache gut. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie schon mal in einem Flugsimulator gesessen haben. Nach spätestens fünf Minuten wissen Sie nicht, dass Sie in einem Simulator sitzen. Sie glauben wirklich, es ist gefährlich, jetzt abzustürzen. Wir hatten ja dort Oliver Knickel in der ersten Runde dabei. Das war so ein Vorlauf, etwas über 100 Tage. Und ich habe mich mit ihm hinterher unterhalten und er hat gesagt, es gab Phasen, da haben wir wirklich geglaubt, wir sind auf dem Weg zum Mars. Und nicht, wir sitzen in einer Büchse in Moskau. Natürlich konnte man dann sagen, ach Mensch, komm, ich sitze doch in der Kiste. Aber dieser Simulationseffekt tritt ein. Und die Mediziner, die die Leute untersucht haben, haben eben auch festgestellt, dass sie, da jetzt auch die Essensaufnahme während dieser Zeit ganz geregelt ist, die wissen genau, was sie zu essen kriegen und was passiert. Haben sie auch jetzt schon, die Mediziner, Ergebnisse bekommen? Zum Beispiel so der Frage Blutdruck. Wie kann ich Blutdruck über Ernährung steuern? Das kann man natürlich auch fangen. Muss ich dafür extra in so eine Büchse steigen? Offensichtlich ist diese hermetische Abkapselung eine ideale Versuchsumgebung auch für andere Fragen, andere Thematiken.
Der Mars ist ja ein, ich würde sagen fast das beliebteste Ziel, was es in der Raumfahrt derzeit zumindest zu geben scheint. Also nicht, dass andere Orte nicht auch besuchen würdig sind, aber vom Mars geht eine bestimmte Faszination aus. Es gab ja auch schon eine ganze Menge Projekte, auch europäische Projekte, vor allem das Mars Express Projekt. Wie ist denn das verlaufen?
Mars und Venus sind die beiden Planeten, die uns am nächsten sind, eben der Mond als Mond. Und beide sind extrem unterschiedlich. Und beide zeigen uns und haben uns auch gezeigt, dass wir mit der Erde sehr sorgsam umgehen müssen. Beide haben einen Treibhauseffekt, der eine positiv, der andere negativ. Auf der Venus heizt sich alles auf und auf dem Mars kühlt sich alles ab. Das heißt, es ist übrigens auch ein Irrglaube, dass der Treibhauseffekt auf der Erde entdeckt wurde. Der Treibhauseffekt wurde auf der Venus entdeckt. Und dann hat man gesagt, wenn wir es da so extrem sehen, dann ist das womöglich auch auf der Erde da und tatsächlich. Also wir lernen erstmal von unserem Planeten auch eine Reihe. Der Mars, da haben Sie recht, hat immer eine Faszination gehabt. Das liegt bestimmt auch daran, dass er ganz gut zu beobachten ist von der Erde. Es gibt einen italienischen Astronomen, der dann dort Kanäle vermutet hat. Und ein Jahr später nochmal geguckt hat und dann sahen die Kanäle anders aus. Dann hat er gesagt, boah, müssen die schnell arbeiten können da oben. Deshalb der Mars hat eine Faszination. Er ist relativ gut erreichbar. Er hat ein Klima, was auch einigermaßen zu beherrschen ist von den Temperaturen. Und deshalb ist der Mars für die Exploration von besonderer Bedeutung. Es gibt Mars Express, eine Mission, die zum Mars geflogen ist, die auch einen Länder dabei hatte. Der hieß Beagle. Der ist auch gelandet. Und ich bin sicher, dem geht es gut. Er hat sich nur nie gemeldet. Der ist so autonom, der hat sich nur nie wieder zurückgemeldet. Wir wissen nicht, ob er noch irgendwo rumfährt. Jedenfalls, diese Mission hat auch eine deutsche Komponente. Es ist eine ESA-Mission, hat eine deutsche Komponente, nämlich eine hochauflösende Stereokamera an Bord. Mit Hilfe derer nun die faszinierenden Bilder von den Bergen und den Tälern auf dem Mars gemacht werden konnten, die die ersten Hinweise auch auf die Existenz von Wassereis auf den Mars gebracht haben und die uns auch gezeigt haben, dass dort irgendwann mal Wasser geflossen sein muss. Da gibt es nämlich so etwas wie ausgetrocknete Flussbette und so etwas. Also der Mars hat die schönen Zeiten seines Lebens auf sich hinter sich. Schön, was wir als Menschen verstehen. Und Mars Express ist eine tolle Mission. Immer noch eine tolle Mission.
Ist also noch...
Immer noch aktiv.
Immer noch aktiv. Der, ähm, was, das Venus, gibt es auch ein Venus-Projekt?
Venus Express.
Venus Express, ach so.
Ja, das ist, nein, nein, das ist, so viel ich weiß, abgeschlossen. Fliegt noch drum herum. Aber die hauptwissenschaftliche Arbeit ist bereits getan. Das ist eine ähnliche Mission. Auch dort mit entsprechenden Bilderfassungen und so weiter. Also dadurch wissen wir auch mehr über die Venus. Aber Sie haben recht, im Moment konzentriert sich alles ein bisschen auf den Mars. Da gibt es ja auch diese Rovers, der Amerikaner, die da seit Jahr und Tag rumfahren. Spirit und Opportunity. Also der Mars ist einfach ein bisschen im Mittelpunkt der Forschung, weil er halt relativ gut erreichbar ist, weil man gut drauf landen kann. Er hat eine Atmosphäre, in der man auch mit Fallschirm arbeiten kann. Er hat eine niedriger Schwerkraft als die Erdanziehung. Deshalb kann man da sehr schön alles organisieren, probieren.
Diese Dualität der Beobachtung auf der Erde und aus dem Orbit mit Mars Express und mit den beiden Robotern, die da immer noch sehr erfolgreich rumkurven. Der eine ist steckfest, aber trotzdem haben die ja bei Weitem soll erfüllt. Kann man da auch so einen kulturellen Unterschied zwischen dem amerikanischen und dem europäischen Ansatz herauslesen?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so vermessen ist, aber diese Roboter scheinen mir schon sehr amerikanisch zu sein. Wenn man sich die Eroberungskultur des Amerikanischen so anschaut, wir müssen auf den Mond, wir müssen da drauf rumlaufen, das ist ja das große nationale Projekt gewesen, war ja dann auch erfolgreich. So ein bisschen haben ja auch diese Roboter das dann eben auch auf den Mars vorgeführt. Dann kommen die Europäer und gehen da sehr akademisch ran. Ich überziehe das jetzt bewusst so und sage, wir müssen das jetzt erstmal alles vermessen. Das hat natürlich also beides seine Qualität, die Projekte ergänzen sich ja auch. Aber gibt es vielleicht einfach eine andere Herangehensweise in der europäischen Raumfahrtkultur im Vergleich zu den amerikanischen? Oder versuche ich da jetzt zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen, wo gar nichts steht?
Ich glaube, wir würden auch schon ganz gerne ein paar Rover auf dem Mars rumfahren lassen. Wir würden auch gerne einen Robonauten, also eine Mischung aus Roboter und Fahrzeug und Astronaut, auf dem Mond schicken. Ich glaube, das würden wir schon auch gerne machen. Das ist natürlich immer eine Frage der finanziellen Möglichkeiten. Und da sind die Amerikaner tatsächlich einen Schritt mutiger. Das heißt, sie setzen auch mal so ein visionäres Target. Und dann machen sie das aber auch. Bei vielen Dingen bin ich immer wieder verpöft. Selbst damals Kennedy, 1963, hat er gesagt, wir wollen zum Mond fliegen und wieder zurück. 1963 hatten die nichts an Technologie, um das zu machen. Die hatten nichts an Technologie. Die hatten noch nie mal die Rechner dafür. Aber sie haben es gemacht. Dieser Charakter ist vielleicht, prägt stark die amerikanische Gesellschaft. Bob der Bilder und Obama haben das Gleiche benutzt. Das ist, glaube ich, eher so stärker die Methode. Wir versuchen es einfach mal. Während da tatsächlich die Europäer sehr viel Wissenschaft, das ist vielleicht der Begriff, den Sie gesagt haben. Ich würde mal ein bisschen vorsichtiger sagen, rangehen und versuchen, alle Risiken vorher auszuschalten. Selbst auf die Gefahren, dass man dann eben deutlich langsamer ist oder auch die Ergebnisse nicht erreicht, die man eigentlich erreichen wollte. Das erscheint mir tatsächlich so. Aber die deutsche und die europäische Raumfahrt ist schon auch sehr mutig. Also sie macht auch schon gute Vorwärtssprünge. Wir versuchen natürlich immer direkt auch Erkenntnisse aus diesen Flügen zu kriegen und nicht nur einfach zu sagen, wir waren da. Also das stimmt, wir würden nicht einen Roboter auf den Mond schicken, nur dass er mal zurückwinkt und eine deutsche Fahne reinsteckt. Sondern wenn der auf dem Mond ist, dann muss der auch wissenschaftlich richtig vernünftig was machen.
Ich glaube, das ist so das, was ich ein bisschen selber gesehen habe mit der Frage. Wir haben ja einige Punkte noch überhaupt nicht angesprochen, aber ein ganz wichtiger Teil der Arbeit des DLR, ein wichtiger Teil auch der ESA, ist ja generell die Erdbeobachtung. Also Einsatz von Satelliten und anderen Techniken. Wir haben es ja im Prinzip jetzt auch mit der Aschelwecke auch schon mal angesprochen. Also wirklich auch die Konzentration auf unseren eigenen Planeten spielt ja eine sehr große Rolle im europäischen Programm. Deswegen sage ich es auch gleich so, diese Verbindung. Man macht im Prinzip dann auf dem Mars auch das, was man vor allem auch auf der Erde macht. Man verbindet da sozusagen auch den Ansatz, sodass auch die Nützlichkeit immer sofort erkennbar wird. Vielleicht können wir ja auch mal den Bogen dann wieder zurückspannen zu diesem Bereich der Erdbeobachtung. Dort geschieht ja eine ganze Menge.
Sie hatten den Begriff der Nützlichkeit eben. Den will ich gerne noch mal aufgreifen, weil er auch für die Erdbeobachtung eine besondere Bedeutung hat. Nützlichkeit kann verschieden interpretiert werden. Da gibt es den Utilaritätsansatz, der sagt, also es muss sich lohnen im Sinne von, ich setze einen Euro ein und ich will 1,50 Euro wieder rauskriegen. Das könnte man jetzt machen bei Erdbeobachtung. Ich setze eine Zahl für einen Satelliten, der mir dafür sorgt, dass meine Ernte besser wird auf der Erde, indem ich dann genauer beobachte aus dem All, wo muss ich jetzt bewässern und so weiter. Das wäre ein Nützlichkeitsansatz. Oder ich gucke aus dem All, wie kann ich Katastrophen ein Stück weit vorhersagen oder begrenzen. Das wäre tatsächlich dieser Nützlichkeitsansatz im Bereich von Euros. Ich sehe aber noch einen anderen Nützlichkeitsansatz. Wenn ich aus dem All Eigenheiten unserer Erde besser verstehen lerne, dann muss das nicht heißen, dass es am nächsten Tag dafür einen Euro gibt. Der Mensch ist meiner Meinung nach, oder ich empfinde das jedenfalls so, der Mensch auch einfach neugierig ist, Dinge zu verstehen. Und das ist auch nützlich, etwas zu verstehen. Das Kind ist neugierig und viele Erwachsene schaffen es, diese Neugier auch zu bewahren. Und ich finde diese Befriedigung dieser Neugier ist auch nützlich. Wenn wir also mit einer Mission das schwere Feld der Erde genau vermessen können, dann hat das keine Wirkung direkt am nächsten Tag auf die Produktion von irgendwelchen Getränken oder irgendwas. Sondern es ist Verständnis, was basiert im Inneren unserer Erde? Wie ist dieses ganze Weltteil überhaupt entstanden? Und die Fragen, die da kommen, sind ja jeden Tag mehr und werden nicht weniger. Das finde ich ja das Faszinierende. Gerade jetzt ist ja wieder die Frage, da hatten wir ein, was man jahrelang als schwarzes Loch klar definiert hat. Plötzlich findet man dort offensichtlich doch Material und Materie. Das heißt, wir kommen auch immer wieder in Widersprüche mit unserer Theorie. Und deshalb ist Nützlichkeit für mich sehr viel breiter aufgestellt als nur der Euro oder der Dollar. Und die Erdbeobachtung befriedigt jetzt mehrere dieser Aspekte. Die Erdbeobachtung hat diese Aspekte der Wetterbeobachtung, des Katastrophenmanagements, bis hin zum Bereich der Landwirtschaft und viele andere Themen. Aber sie hat eben auch diese Aspekte zu verstehen. Was ist mit dieser gesamten Erde überhaupt los? Wie ist die entstanden? Was heißt das, wenn das Magnetfeld der Erde sich verschiebt? Was passiert da? Klimawandel, all diese Geschichten.
Was sind denn gute Beispiele für Erdbeobachtungsprojekte, die derzeit laufen oder in Planung sind?
Aus deutscher Sicht ist sicherlich die Radar-Mission TerraSatX und TandemX zu nennen. TerraSatX ist ein Radarsatellit, ein aktiver Satellit, der also über Radartechnologie über die Erde Auskunft gibt. Radartechnologie hat folgenden großen Wert, wenn sie einen normalen optischen Satelliten nimmt, dann guckt er auf die Erde. Ist es hell, ist es hell, ist es dunkel, ist es dunkel, ist es nebel, ist es nebel. Das heißt, zum Beispiel beim Katastrophen-Management ist häufig Flutkatastrophe mit schlechtem Wetter verbunden. Dann können Sie mit einem optischen Satelliten gerade nichts sehen von dieser Flutkatastrophe. TerraSatX hat nun einen Radar an Bord und kann dann eben auch durch Nebel hindurchsehen, durch Wolken hindurchsehen. Er kann Tag und Nacht die Erde beobachten. Er kann Bewegungen, wie auch im Straßenverkehr, besonders gut verfolgen. Deshalb ist diese Radartechnologie ein ganz ausgezeichnetes Instrument. TerraSatX ist vor drei Jahren gestartet. Jetzt haben wir einen neuen Satelliten dazu bekommen. Tandem ist fast baugleich zu TerraSatX. Auch ein Radar-Satellit. Die beiden fliegen jetzt in Formation und können dadurch ein dreidimensionales Geländemodell der gesamten Erde in bisher nicht bekannter Präzision aufbauen. Also die fliegen zusammen und können dann Stereo-Aufnahmen machen. Es gab schon ein paar Radar-Missionen mit Stereomethoden. Aber diese ist jetzt mit einer Genauigkeit, die man bisher nicht kannte. Und das ist eine technologisch unglaubliche Herausforderung. Zwei Satelliten im engen Formationsflug um die Erde kreisen zu lassen und sie aber nicht gegeneinander stürzen zu lassen.
Eng im Sinne von ein Abstand von?
800 Metern.
Das ist ja eigentlich im Weltall-Maßstab eigentlich nichts.
Das ist nichts. Sie nähern sich. Im Moment sind sie noch zig Kilometer auseinander. Sie nähern sich langsam. Und das ist eine besondere Herausforderung. Sie dürfen sich nicht, und sie können nicht einfach parallel um die Erde fliegen. Das gibt die Mechanik nicht her, sondern die fliegen beide eine eigene Bahn um die Erde. Und dadurch verändert sich auch diese Zuordnung zur Erde permanent. Die fliegen also so eine Doppelspiralform, würde man vielleicht sagen, untereinander. Sie umfliegen sich immer gegenseitig. Und das ist eine besondere Herausforderung. Und die Technik, die dabei angewandt wird und auch die Überwachung, das ist wiederum eine technische Meisterleistung. Das ist also so ein Bereich. Und dann haben wir den Bereich der optischen Satelliten in verschiedenen Frequenzbereichen. Da gibt es eine Reihe von europäischen Projekten. Da gibt es auch weltweit Dinge, wo wir auf die Daten zugreifen können. Und dann gibt es eben solche Sondersatelliten, wie zum Beispiel der ESA-Satellit Goche, ein Raumschiff, was sehr niedrig um die Erde herumkreist. Und zwar so niedrig, dass es dauernd durch die Erdatmosphäre sehr stark abgebremst würde. Und deshalb hat dieser Satellit ein Ionentriebwerk an Bord, also keinen chemischen Antrieb, sondern einen elektrischen Antrieb, um diesem Widerstand dauernd mit einem eigenen Antrieb entgegenzuwirken. Und Goche soll das schwere Feld der Erde besser vermessen. Und das ist eine der Missionen, die auch für die Erdbeobachtung von großer Bedeutung sind, für das wissenschaftliche Verständnis. Das schwere Feld ist alles andere als gleich verteilt um die Erde. Und das heißt, dass die Erde nicht ganz rund ist, das hat man schon relativ früh erkannt. Aber zu dem Verständnis, wie ist der innere Aufbau der Erde und wie ist die Entstehung und die Geschichte eines solchen Himmelskörpers, ist die Anziehungskraft eine der ganz zentralen Fragestellungen. Das gilt im großen Maßstab, im kleinen Maßstab wissen wir ja bis heute, nicht, wie Schwerkraft funktioniert. Das muss man auch sehen. Also versucht man ja an anderer Stelle, Gleichheit zu kriegen. Also hier kommt auch wieder der Makrokosmos und der Mikrokosmos zusammen. Einerseits zu verstehen, wie das schwere Feld der Erde wirkt und andererseits, was dann schwere überhaupt Gravitation bedeutet. Wir wissen darüber insgesamt tatsächlich noch nicht sehr viel. Da sind zum Beispiel in den 70er Jahren zwei amerikanische Missionen gestartet, Pionier 10 und 11. Die sind einfach weit ins Weltall hinausgeschossen worden. Die hatten dann so Plaketten an Bord, falls sie von irgendwelchen außerirdischen Lebewesen identifiziert werden, dass die wissen, woher man kam. Diese Plakette ist ja damals weltweit bekannt gewesen mit Mann und Frau und dem Sonnensystem. Und man hat verfolgt, wo diese beiden langfliegen und hat das mit allen Rechenprogrammen nachgerechnet. Und tatsächlich fliegen die anders, als sie nach unseren gängigen Vorstellungen der Himmelsmechanik fliegen müssten. Also passiert da irgendwas. Schwerkraft oder was auch immer es ist. Deshalb ist Schwerkraft zu verstehen eine der ganz grundlegenden Aspekte. Daneben gibt es noch die Fragen dunkler Energie und dunkle Materie. Aber da gibt es eine Reihe von Fragen. Wir wissen noch nicht mal fünf Prozent, wie es funktioniert. Das muss man sich klar machen. Von dem Himmel wissen wir, dass wir nicht alles kennen. Das ist ja klar. Das ist einfach zu groß. Aber von der Logik, die dahinter steht, haben wir noch nicht einmal fünf Prozent verstanden.
Das heißt, an der Stelle ist die Erdbeobachtung, die durchgeführt wird, vor allem Grundlagenforschung und arbeitet den Wissenschaftlern auf der Ebene zu.
Wenn Sie an Wetter denken, ganz und gar nicht, dann ist es auch Anwendung.
An Wetter? Ja gut, aber ich meine jetzt beim Spierefeld...
Ja, dieser Bereich ist eher Grundlagenforschung.
Genau, aber es gibt ja auch andere Beispiele von...
Erdbeobachtung, was ich vorher gesagt habe mit den Radarsatelliten, das ist eine unmittelbare Anwendung im Fall von Katastrophen, im Fall von Klimawandel. Wir können mit den Radarsatelliten zum Beispiel sehr schön auch das Abschmelzen der Eisbereiche in Arktis und Antarktis verfolgen. Und wir können eben auch mit geostationären Satelliten, die ja dann nicht von ESA, sondern von Eumetsat betrieben werden, aber von ESA entwickelt werden, auch Wettervorhersage in Europa, in der ganzen Welt durchführen. Also Erdbeobachtung hat ganz viele Facetten.
Ja, ich wollte noch auf eine Facette hinzusteuern, nämlich vor wenigen Monaten ist ja der Cryosat-2 gestartet, der ja die Wesentlichen, die Dicke der polaren Eisschicht messen soll. Das ist ja nun ein ganz konkreter Beitrag zur Klimaforschung.
Es ist die Frage, ob sie das als Anwendung oder als Grundlagenforschung sehen würden. Das ist nämlich ein typischer Fall, bei dem sie das nicht entscheiden können. Ich persönlich versuche auch, diese beiden Begriffe nicht so trennscharf zu benutzen. Also es ist sicherlich das Verständnis, was passiert da in der Arktis, was passiert in der Antarktis, ist ganz wichtig. Es sollte auch dann daraus politische Entscheidungen oder weltpolitische Entscheidungen getroffen werden. Also die Situation ist alles andere als lustig, was den Klimawandel angeht. Und Gruesatt 2 wird dazu beitragen, das Verständnis zu haben, was passiert da. Und diese Aufnahme, da folgt ja noch nichts raus. Der nächste Schritt ist dann, dass auch politische Handlungen und vielleicht auch Gegenmaßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen.
Jenseits der Erdbeobachtung spielt ja auch Navigation eine große Rolle. Schon seit sehr langer Zeit im Gespräch ist das Projekt Galileo.
Navigation hat eine ganz lange Tradition, ist ursprünglich umgekehrt entstanden. Also nicht die Navigation auf der Erde festzulegen, wo ich auf der Erde bin, sondern die Grundlagen sind entwickelt worden, umgekehrt von Hobbyastronomen, die mit der Methode die Position von Satelliten bestimmen wollten. Also das ist wirklich schon 50 Jahre alt, 60 Jahre alt. Dann kam die amerikanische Entwicklung GPS, insbesondere für den militärischen Bereich. Und jetzt versuchen wir eben auch europäisch dort ein eigenes System aufzubauen. Galileo, das ist keine europäische Heitelkeit, sondern dahinter stehen zum einen technologische Entwicklungsnotwendigkeiten, die wir auch in Europa haben, aber auch Chancen im Bereich der Industrie. Und wir werden dieses System auch kompatibel machen, insbesondere zu GPS, sodass der Nutzer dann wirklich beide Systeme auch voll in seinem Gerät nutzen kann. Das hat einen Vorteil dann, wenn sie in Bereichen sind, wo sie zum Beispiel in Häuserschluchten oder anderen oder besonderen Gebirgsverhältnissen, wo sie nicht genügend Satelliten gleichzeitig über sich haben von einem System, dann können sie die Satelliten von dem anderen System noch mitnehmen. Sie brauchen immer mehrere Satelliten, um ihren Ort wirklich eindeutig festzulegen. Da sie Navigation genannt hatten, da sollten wir auch gleich nochmal weiter darüber reden, sage ich nur nochmal, die Raumfahrt hat eben auch neben dieser Erdbeobachtung auch noch diesen Navigationsaspekt, den Kommunikationsaspekt gleichermaßen. Also auch Kommunikation ohne Satelliten ginge nicht. Die Fußballweltmeisterschaft ohne Satelliten wäre ziemlich langweilig, weil man das alles erst sehr viel später kriegen würde. Aber zurück zur Navigation. Galileo ist ein eigenständiges europäisches System. Geplant sind 30 Satelliten auf drei unterschiedlichen Umlaufbahnen. Von diesen 30 Satelliten sollen dann permanent 27 im Betrieb sein. Drei Satelliten sind Reservesatelliten, weil immer mal was passieren kann. Und ein Navigationssystem mit hohem Anspruch an die Zuverlässigkeit braucht auch Reserve im Orbit. Mit Galileo könnten wir viele neue Bereiche erschließen, zum Beispiel auch ganz praktische Anwendungen. Nicht nur im Auto, da benutzen wir es alle. Im Flugverkehr als zuverlässige Quelle ist im Moment GPS allein nicht ausreichend. Da könnte Galileo einen deutlichen Sprung bringen, um auch dann entsprechend Anflüge und Abflüge über Navigationssysteme zu steuern. Da ist das DLR sehr weit vorne auch in der Forschung dabei. Warum ist Navigationsanflug etwas besonders Wichtiges? Wir haben in Deutschland eine Situation, dass wir bei unseren Flughäfen sehr viel Bebauung drum herum haben. Der gerade Anflug auf den Flughafen ist nicht unbedingt der, der ein Minimum an Lärm bei der Bevölkerung bringt. Deshalb kann eine Verschränkung des Anfluges sehr sinnvoll sein. Zum Beispiel um einen großen Ort drum herum zu fliegen. Dafür braucht man ein sicheres System. Da funktionieren die bisherigen einfachen Leitsysteme nicht. Da ist Navigationsanflug dann das Richtige. Dort muss man aber ein System haben, das so sicher ist, dass es auch jederzeit funktioniert. Da wird Galileo etwas Großartiges bringen.
Wie weit ist Galileo noch von seiner Realisierung entfernt?
Wir haben im All zwei Satelliten von Galileo. Die beiden werden aber bei den 27 bzw. 30 noch nicht mitgezählt. Wir müssen zusehen, dass die Satelliten in den nächsten Jahren starten. 2013 und 2014 sollten wir ein funktionsfähiges Galileo-System haben.
So, jetzt haben wir hier schon eine ganze Reihe von Projekten besprochen. Trotzdem wollen wir hier erst mal langsam zum Ende kommen. Zum Ende wollte ich noch mal einen ganz anderen Aspekt aufbringen, nämlich woher beziehen eigentlich ESA und DLR so ihr Personal? Gibt es denn da so eine ganz eigene Ausbildungsförderung? Kann man sich schon zum Raumfahrtspezialisten schon von vornherein einschulen lassen? Oder ist das eigentlich so, dass der Großteil der Mitarbeiter, die hier sind, vor allem aus einer Vielzahl anderer Disziplinen kommen, die sich so erstmal nicht unbedingt in Richtung Raumfahrt ausbilden lassen? Sind das alles so Interdisziplinäre? Was für Möglichkeiten gibt es denn, sich einzubringen?
Was wir wirklich brauchen, sind Leute, sind Frauen und Männer, die an den Themen des DLR ihren Spaß haben. Wir können nicht die Gehälter zahlen, die in der Industrie üblich sind. Und gleichzeitig verlangen wir im Prinzip aber mehr Leistung. Das ist eine etwas schwierige Situation. Wir haben aber zum Glück über 6.500 Menschen gefunden, die diese Begeisterung teilen für die verschiedenen Themen. Und das gilt für alle Bereiche auch im DLR. Auch in der Verwaltung die Menschen oder auch in der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit oder in den Instituten sind eben begeistert von den Themen und sehen das nicht als einfachen Job. Das ist jedenfalls meine Erfahrung. Wie können wir solche Leute finden? Wir versuchen das schon in der Schule zu unterstützen. Wir haben DLR School Labs eingerichtet. Das sind Schüleralabore, in denen Schülerinnen und Schüler kommen mit ihren ganzen Klassen und dann ein komplettes Programm durchziehen. Also nicht mal besuchen, so ganz schön was ihr macht, sondern die machen dann richtig Programme. Die bauen dann eben einen kleinen Teststand auf für die Schwerelosigkeit oder sie machen eine Energieforschung unmittelbar oder sie machen andere Projekte, bauen kleine Rakete mit Wasser etc. Das ist die erste Stufe, die wir eingebaut haben. Dann haben wir, dadurch dass alle unsere Institutsleiter gleichzeitig Professoren an deutschen Universitäten sind, die Verbindung zu den Studierenden. Und dann haben wir jetzt aufgebaut ganz neu im Bereich der Doktorandenphase. Wir haben viele Doktoranden im DLR. Wir haben ein DLR-Graduate-Programm aufgebaut, bei dem wir auch noch mal die verschiedenen, faszinierenden Bereiche des DLRs und Kompetenzen vermitteln wollen. Natürlich durchaus in dem Interesse, dass möglichst viele dann auch sagen, das ist der Bereich, in dem ich tätig werde. Und wenn sie sagen, wir gehen lieber woanders hin, dann glauben wir, sie sind bestens gerüstet durch die Vorarbeiten im DLR.
Welche Studiengänge sind denn sozusagen die typischen Vorbereitungen für...
Von A bis Z. Sie können als Jurist zum DLR kommen, Sie können als Raumfahrt-Techniker und wie ich ja vorhin gesagt habe, sogar selbst als Bauingenieur finden Sie hier noch was.
Stimmt, man kann dann sogar Vorstandsvorsitzender werden. Richtig. Welche Rolle spielt die Informatik in der Raumfahrt?
Eine permanente. Ohne Computer läuft da gar nichts. Und wir haben im DLR auch dafür eine spezielle Einrichtung. Concurrent Engineering, das ist ein System, da werden an mehreren Rechnern gleichzeitig Aspekte, Probleme bearbeitet. Da treffen sich dann die Experten aus den verschiedenen Bereichen und über den Computer im selben Raum kommunizieren sie für eine Mission ihre eigenen Vorstellungen. Also der eine sagt, wir müssen auf die Windkanal-Tüchtigkeit hinweisen, der andere sagt vielleicht, wir brauchen aber hier noch eine Steuerung, der Dritte sagt, wir brauchen einen Antrieb, der Vierte sagt, wir brauchen eine Nutzlast. Das wird über die Informatik zusammengebunden. Informatik im weitesten Bereich ist alles im DLR, hat irgendwie auch mit Informatik zu tun, ob das die Berechnung von Strömungen sind oder von neuen Antrieben oder die Nutzung der Elektronik als Kommunikation.
Wie funktioniert da die Kooperation mit den Universitäten und den entsprechenden Informatikinstituten? Gibt es da permanenten Kontakt?
Wir haben sehr enge Verbindung mit den Universitäten. Ich sagte ja schon, dass die Institutsdirektoren alle auch Professoren an Universitäten sind. Darüber hinaus haben wir ein neues Instrument aufgebaut. Das nennen wir DLR at Uni. Da gründen wir lokal zwischen dem jeweiligen DLR-Standort und der jeweiligen Universität einen ganz engen Verbund, um dort auch die Kompetenzen aus der Universität und dem DLR zusammenzuführen. Wir haben das jetzt gemacht in Braunschweig. Wir haben es gemacht in Stuttgart, in München und wir werden es auch in Berlin machen. Aber wir haben auch zusätzlich den Austausch, also auch nicht nur die Institutsdirektoren, sondern auch viele Abteilungsleiter in den Instituten sind gleichzeitig in der Forschung und Lehre an den Universitäten aktiv. Also wir haben dort eine sehr intensive Verbindung und das muss auch so sein.
Welche Universität betrifft Berlin?
In Berlin haben wir mit der TU Berlin eine sehr enge Beziehung, aber auch mit der Humboldt-Uni.
Und wenn jetzt so jemand in seinem Studium sich, sagen wir mal, den Raumfahrt-Themen zu geneigt fühlt, was ist da so die beste Möglichkeit der Spezialisierung?
Die beste Möglichkeit ist erstmal, sich bei uns zu melden, um mal ein Praktikum im DLR zu machen, um mal zu sehen, welcher Bereich ist denn jetzt das, was für mich am spannendsten ist. Und dann sage ich, ist es fast gleichgültig, ob man sich stärker im elektrotechnischen Bereich, Maschinenbau oder in anderen Bereichen tummelt. Man wird später sowieso sehr viel mehr noch dazulernen müssen. Das Studium ist eine wichtige Grundlage, aber es reicht schon ganz und gar nicht bis zum Lebensende oder bis zum Arbeitsende. Und dafür bietet das DLR aber auch die Möglichkeit, sich dann weiterzubilden. Aber diese Faszination, die können wir nicht bilden. Die muss in einem einzelnen drin stecken. Also Faszination und eine saubere, gute Ausbildung, ich will nicht sagen, egal in welchem Bereich, aber das ist erstmal wichtig. Natürlich ist das DLR insbesondere auf Technik und Naturwissenschaften ausgerichtet. Aber wie ich schon gesagt habe, wir haben auch Juristen, wir haben auch Volkswirte, wir haben alle verschiedenen Bereiche. Wir machen ja auch Psychologie, wir machen die Auswahlgeschichte für die Lufthansa, für alle Piloten. Und wir betreiben gemeinsam mit dem Land Rheinland-Pfalz die Europäische Akademie. Dort machen wir so etwas wie Technikfolgenabschätzung. Also wir haben wirklich alle Disziplinen mit einer klaren Ausrichtung auf Luftfahrt, Raumfahrt, Energie, Verkehr und Sicherheit.
Ja, Jan Wörner, vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Ich denke, hier machen wir dann einen Punkt für die erste Ausgabe, aber die letzte soll es nicht sein. In der Folge werden wir ein breites Spektrum an Themen hier einbringen. Wir werden viele Sachen aufgreifen, die in diesem Podcast genannt werden. Wir werden aber auch viele Sachen aufgreifen, die jetzt hier mangels der Zeit leider noch keinen Platz gefunden haben. Dann wiederum mit noch etwas größerem Detail. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Das war ein sehr interessanter Einblick in die Arbeit des DLR und der ESA. Und vielen Dank auch an alle, die jetzt hier reingeschaltet haben. Und ich hoffe, ihr bleibt hier auch dem Programm treu. Ich sage erstmal Tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.